俺の名前は天才小学生屋根す。
やねちゃん。お使いってきなさい。
ええ。ほら、行ってこい。
無理やりお使いに行かされます。
待て。このまま続けたら父さんだ。君みたいな天才を求めていた。今日から君が店長になってこのスーパーを守ってくれ。
[音楽]
ええ。
もしも天才小学生がスーパーの店長になったら、その後俺はこのスーパーの経営を立て直すため迷惑の体を任された。
[音楽]
最初のターゲットはこいつだ。
特売セールバ8
時か。売れ残った商品に半額シールを貼る時間だ。出たな。
特売セルバ
やったわ。あ、フィジカル強すぎや。
やだ。触ったでようかね。
あら、やだ。これちょっと高いわね。
それじゃあ半額にしちゃえばいいじゃない?ふ。
[音楽]
ちょっと勝手にシールを貼るのですよ。
証拠は防犯カメラに残ってるかしら。
こいつら防犯カメラの資格になるように人系を組んでやがれ。
よいしょ。よいしょ。
これ気にしないキ甘い蜜。半額最高出ちゃう配置。
[音楽]
安けりゃ安いほどいいんじゃない。金稼ぐより節約ビューティホライ
1000円になります。
おい、商品を戻せ。
税ジを通した商品は返品ってお店が書いてるでしょ。また来るわね。
くそ。
[音楽]
お母様方、今日は大量な半額シール用意したのでごに使ってください。
いいの
[音楽]
にしないは120万円でございます。
はあ。そ、そんなわけのどうなってるの?
それは特殊な加工をしたリインクを使ったシールだ。冷たい時は決晶状態で光の反射が変わって半額に見える。でも温度が上がると熱で分子配列が崩れて倍学が出てくる。
こ返品よ。一
レジを通した商品は返品負荷です。
ゴー
半額バ財布からカラ計算苦手なただのおバカ全肉ジャマ誇れんママセルより痩せるの大事なマナーしてください。
[音楽]
[拍手]
次のターゲットはこいつだ。
2世金2世金
はい、じゃあ回すよ。ドンキドキンピン
[音楽]
キ勝手にバイトガローYouTube。
どうもニ世金とどうもニ世金TV
のニ世金です。
[音楽]
はい。2
世金勝手にアルバイト私金がいろんな職業を勝手に体験させていただく企画です。それでは行きますよ。ブ。
ブンブン。
[音楽]
それでは冷凍き勝手に試食したいと思います。こ焼きにゃん。シャーペットだ。マイナス
120点。
[音楽]
まずお客さん迷惑行為をやめてください。
迷惑行為だって。こっちは仕事でやったぞ。あ、ほら、金払えばいいんだろ。受け取れ。アップロード。アップロード。パチ。ダシットダマ
120点。
[音楽]
広告めちゃくちゃ儲かる。はい。じゃあ回すよ。
偽勝手にアルバイト2
動画見ました。ニさんとニ世金さんですよね。今日は僕らスーパー案内するのでついてきてください。
[音楽]
なんか入れちゃった。うお。
ようわからんがついて行ってみます。
[音楽]
こっちです。こっちです。た、
こっちです。お、
ここがうちの冷凍室です。
あ、ちょっと待っててくださいね。
ヤネキTVエブデイ。
僕天才ですからどうもネきです。今日の企画はキ
YouTuberを楽しめてみた。
今この冷凍室の中に迷惑系
YouTuberが2
人いるんですけど、この冷凍室の温度をめちゃくちゃ下げてこいつらを凍らせたいと思います。
[音楽]
じゃあ回すね。
それではここの冷凍室めちゃくちゃに荒らしたいと思います。おい、なんか寒くねえか?寒い、寒い、寒い、寒い。
[音楽]
[拍手]
うわ、シャーレットだ。あ。うん。次のターゲットがこいつだ。
[音楽]
万引きマジシャン来たな。万引シャ。
消えた。これは現行犯で捕まえられそうだな。
ありがとうございました。お客様、レジを通されてない商品がございますよね。はあ。
[音楽]
ちょっとお体の方調べさせていただきますね。
あれ?見当たらない。人を犯罪者扱いするのか?警察呼ぞ。申し訳ございません。全く。
[笑い]
一体どうやって?このトリックが分かったぞ。
[音楽]
ありがとうございました。またお前か。今度こそ本当に警察呼んでやろうか。
お前のトリック全部見破ったぞ。お前のカートを持っていた手、あれはダミーだ。お前はマントと商品が重なった瞬間に素早く商品を盗み、他の客に貼り付けた。
それを出口付近で回収したってわけだろ。や、お見事。お前を盗剤で現行反対砲。
[笑い]
それじゃあさようなら。危なかったわい。
[音楽]
な、なんだこれ?
な、なんでせべが光ってるんだ?
GPS入りのせは美味しい。
ど、どうして?
あんたがおじいさんでせ好きなのは亡くなった商品から予想がついたよ。だから先に
GPSを仕込んでおいたのさ。逮捕だ。
おお。おい、来い。来い。大しくしろ。
[音楽]
最後のターゲットはこいつだ。
お母さん。お母さんはベニール袋を大量に取るし、
1人1
個のルールも守らないし。試食は全部食べちゃうし。
[音楽]
最悪な迷惑だ。
おっと。
お客さん無料だからテクロなんでもひどすぎます。
だったら最初から有料にすればいいじゃない。
いやいやいや無料っていうのはお客様との死んだりになり立っていて込めうるさい。うわ、
[音楽]
こりゃ1筋縄じゃかないな。
あら、これ無料じゃないの?
いや、レス君、なんでわざわざ無料のものを増やすんだ。
僕に考えがあります。私のは大根だ。
あんなの95°そろそろだな。お母さんいい加減みたいなことやめたな。誰が食ですって?これでも食らえ。
[音楽]
あ、あんた私とやり合うきもう勝負は終わってるけどね。はあ。激辛を食べて上がったお母さんの体温でトウモロコシが焼けるとポップコーンになって口からは弾け飛ぶ。
ほら、これまで店に与えた損害分払ってもらおうか。
えっと、えっと、あ、あ、ちょっと財布
忘れちゃったわ。へえ
。うわあ
、待て
[音楽]
。この激辛を使うしかない
。うわあ、これでも暗え
。お、何これ?何これ?おお。ああ
。あ、あ、あわ。
あやあ、お金がなくてつい。お金がないなら仕方ない。代わりにうちで働いてもらうよ。
[音楽]
はい、頑張ります。き子さん、ちゃんとやってるかい?美人店員き子のコ食いタイム
君は首だ。
おら、
人間ですぐには変わんないね。
グッズが変えるようになったのでみんなチェックしてね。